welcome back well the count
uh the clock is counting down so let's
get to the
end of our show does anyone have a
question
i do hi kristen how are you
hi guys oh my goodness
what is that cute family and doggie
hello
hi how are you doing
great thank you how are you guys doing
i mean we're doing great you know we're
in quarantine with each other
and so there's been a lot of
togetherness oh you have all these
beautiful girls and kids and a doggie
what's your doggie's name
our dog's name is drew she's named after
you actually
wait i did not know this are you kidding
me
wait i am not giving you can i ask what
drew was the inspiration
yes so um we had some infertility issues
about 17 years ago and
um she's named after you because i
thought
that she was going to be my last baby
and
um so i always wanted a baby moon drew
and i got one so we have wilton hummer
here more live andrew oh my gosh okay
we're gonna offline about this
hi everybody
oh my gosh okay so before i
say hi to everyone wait kristen
i what happened because one minute
you're doing ivf
and the next minute you have this dog
named drew which i'm just so honored to
be a part of your life
and then you have all these beautiful
children behind you
yes so um we were
i was diagnosed with pcos um right after
we got married and they told us that if
we didn't start
having children that we probably
wouldn't be able to have biological ones
um and so i we did nine rounds
and we finally got our lily who is our
oldest
17 hi lily
and then um two miscarriages and 10
years later
um i decided that well we decided
that um maybe this wasn't what was
planned for us maybe one kid was what we
had
god had planned for us so we went on
petfinder.com just one random saturday
and the weird part about that yes the
weird part about that is
your face was on the website when we got
there
um and i don't know i know you're i know
what website you're talking about
yeah yeah but it was just just a random
thing and we scrolled down and we found
this litter of rescue puppies
and they all had names of rock bands
and she was queen which i don't mean
um and but we had always planned that if
we had a baby
that that baby but whether it be a boy
or girl would be named after you
and um so we found this rescue pup
and she is now drew norman
and she her birth date actually dated
back to february
and and you and my grandmother are both
born
on february 22nd so she we dubbed her
birthday
february 22nd as well oh my god
fast forward one year i was not feeling
well
and to rule everything out i took a
pregnancy test
and didn't think anything of it and it
came back
completely positive on the first try and
we found out we were pregnant with eric
hi eric
[Music]
and nine months after that or when he
was nine months old i found out i was
pregnant with summer
and when summer was nine months old i
found out i was pregnant with lorelai
oh my gosh this is incredible hi
wow so hey
mister i got a question yes
what kind of pet you got okay
that's a good question because i have a
bearded dragon named jeremy
we have a yellow parrot named sunshine
we have two cats named lucky and peach
we have two dogs named douglas and lucy
by the way to
your mom and dad i'm really sorry that
i'm telling you all this because now
you're all gonna want pets and i'm
really sorry for being
a bad influence um and we have
a couple of guinea pigs um
and um that don't really interact much
i've come to find
uh and a little tiny white mouse
and i do i love little tiny white mice
they're just so cute
um so we have we have a zoo
that's awesome
go ahead laura miss drew yeah
your question she's waiting um me do you
have a wine at your house
a lion yeah yes every time i try to
brush olives hair
she turns into a wild cat and tries to
scratch my face off so yes i do
her name is olive she turns eight this
saturday actually
wow yes
lily how old are you oh yes go ahead
eric
i'm
um
do you do you have any goldfish
you know we did have some goldfish um
and um they lived for several years
which is very impressive in the goldfish
universe
and um we also had like the japanese
uh bettas they they they can only be
alone but they have those beautiful fan
tails and they're really low maintenance
so the goldfish needed the tank and the
filter and like
it got really kind of out of control um
but the betas are are nice and simple
well may i ask you a question yes
absolutely
okay so since you love animals so much
what inspired you
to become an animal lover and
specifically rescue animals
i just i think i really empathize with
animals
and i can see that they
need love and especially the more
domestic ones you know
obviously i'm not you know bringing home
elephants and things like that but
um that would be fun but you know it's
like
they're out and they need a home and so
i just and my daughters
love my daughter olive i choose my first
so i didn't have any comparison
and she is we call her aceventura she is
obsessed with animals i've never seen
another kid as obsessed with her and she
has the gift
she calms them she catches wild ducks
there's always like rescue dogs when we
like travel that she'll bring home it's
like it never ends and it's
it's such a wild adventure i'm on with
her and
i figure of all the boundaries and rules
i have with her
that i didn't want pets to be a battle
i'm like
safety and manners that is
matters to me you want to have a bunch
of pets
and we have chickens too we have six
chickens
oh my goodness you guys so we're
homeschooling
because of the pandemic and we just
learned about the life cycle of chickens
this week and we went to the farm and
the farmer
learned us to catch chickens and taught
us how to catch chicken that's true
well i really i'm really bonded with the
chicken
like again the guinea pigs i'm like they
don't they don't interact with you they
don't want to be held they're very
standoffish but the chickens they come
and they'll sit down with me and i raise
them since they were little babies
and whenever i walk in their area i go
hello
and cheekys they know they know me and
they're really great i have to say like
the bearded dragon jeremy and the
chickens were the big surprise of like
animals and how fun they can be but i
just
thank you so much for including us in
your amazing adventure
and to everyone else who's here you all
look so fantastic
and i oh look an orange kitty oh i love
you so much oh and like that beautiful
golden doggy and
oh
[Music]